another piece of criticism or by way of
question
is how's assembly Theory or maybe
assembly index different from kog
complexity so for people who don't know
kog complexity of an object is the
length of a shortest computer program
that produces the object as
output yeah I'm I I seem to there seems
to be a disconnect between the
computational approach there so yeah so
comol off measure requires a touring
machine requires a
computer um and that's one thing and the
other thing
is um assembly theory is supposed to
trace the process by which life
Evolution emerged right there's a main
thing there there are lots of other
layers so so Kolarov
complexity you can you can approximate
Comm grof complexity but it's not really
telling you very much about the actual
um it it's really telling you about like
your D your data set compression of your
data set sure and so that doesn't really
help you identify the the turtle in this
case is the computer M and so what
assembly Theory does is I I'm going to
say it's a trigger warning for anyone
listening is's who loves complexity
Theory think that we're going to show
that AIT is a very important subset of
assembly Theory because here's what
happens that um I think that assembly
Theory allows us to build um go
understand when with selections
occurring selection produces um
factories and things factories in the
End Produce computers and you can go
then algorithmic information Theory
comes out of that the frustration I've
had with with looking at life through
this kind of information Theory is it
doesn't take into account causation so
the main difference between assembly
Theory and all these complexity measures
is there's no caal chain yeah in and I
think that's the main the caal chain is
at the at the at the core of uh assembly
Theory exactly and if you're if you've
got all your data in a computer memory
all the data is the same you can access
it in the same time way there's you
don't care you just compress it and and
uh you either look at the program
runtime or the shortest program and that
for
me it is
absolutely not capturing What It Is What
It selection does but assembly Theory
looks at objects it doesn't have
information about the object history
it's going to try to infer that
history by uh looking for the shortest
history right the object the object
doesn't like uh have a a Wikipedia page
that goes with it history I would say it
does in a way and it is fascinating to
look at so you've just got the object M
and you have no other information about
the object what assembly Theory allows
you to do with just with the object is
to and and the the word infer is correct
I agree you infer so you like say well
that's not the that's not the history
but but something really interesting
comes from this the shortest path is
inferred from the object that is the
worst case scenario if you have no
machine to make it so that tells you
about the depth of that object in time
mhm and so what assembly Theory allows
you to do is without considering any
other circumstances to say from this
object how deep is this object in time
if um we just treat the object as itself
without any other any other constraints
and that's super powerful because the
shortest path then says allows you to
say oh this object wasn't just created
randomly there was a process and so
assembly theory is not not meant to you
know one up AIT or to ignore the factory
it's just to say it's just to say hey
there was a factory mhm that and how big
was that factory and how deep in time is
it but it's still
computationally very difficult to
compute uh that history right for
complex objects it it is it becomes
harder one of the thing that's super
nice is that um it constrains your
initial condition right it constrains
where you're going to be so if you take
say imagine so one of the things we're
doing right now is applying assembly
Theory to drug Discovery now what
everyone's doing right now is taking all
the proteins and looking at the proteins
and and looking at molecules do with the
proteins why not instead take the mo
look at the molecules that are involved
interacting with the receptors over time
rather thinking about and use the
molecules evolve over time as a proxy
for how the proteins evolved over time
mhm and then use that to constrain your
drug Discovery process you flip the
problem 180 and focus on the molecule
Evolution rather than the protein and so
you can guess in the future what might
happen so that so that so you rather
than having to consider all possible
molecules you know where to focus and
that's the same thing if you're looking
at in assembly spaces for a object where
you don't know the entire history but
you know that um you know in the history
of this object is not going to have some
other teeth that there that um it
doesn't apply doesn't appear in the past
but just even for the drug Discovery
Point you made isn't don't you have to
simulate all of chemistry
for uh to figure out how to come up with
con constraints no from the molecules
and the no I mean I don't I don't know
enough about protein well this is
another thing that I think causes
because this paper goes across so many
boundar so chemists have looked at this
and said um this is not a this is not a
Rea this is not correct reaction
it's like no it's a
graph sure there's there's a assembly
index and shortest path examples here on
chemistry yeah and so and what you do is
you look at the minimal constraints on
that graph of course it has some mapping
to the synthesis but actually you don't
have to know all of chemistry you just
have to you can build up the constraint
space rather nicely mhm um but this is
just at the beginning right there so
many directions just could go in and as
I said it it could all be wrong but
hopefully it's less
wrong